but yeah how have you guys been in the
past few days Connor you've been uh
taking care of your parents right I have
yeah first time right yeah yeah that's
what that first time in Japan well
everyone I'm Connor's Dad
why are you talking like you're in a
conference I don't know family's coming
in I'm showing there hi everybody we're
in Japan moment visiting Connor for the
first time
right every time anything happened I was
like I'll tell that on the podcast and
they're all like
don't don't say that
why have there been like already I mean
it's just like you know my my parents
because like I think a lot of people who
travel to Japan especially our age like
they like are already kind of into Japan
and already have like researched a bunch
yeah
um they don't get normally like just
dragged here and even like people who
like want to visit here will normally
like look up stuff to do or we'll look
up something and and so my parents kind
of like even though they are interested
in Japan and they they were really
really excited for the trip like they
didn't like research they weren't like
oh my God what's on syntheticator oh my
God how should I well they don't have to
because yeah yeah yeah
and like I realized oh my God I have to
like I have to explain everything right
whereas like sometimes your friends come
over it's like okay I don't have to
explain everything and they can get
around well like they didn't know
anything yeah a lot of those people who
visited kind of have their own motives
already right yeah they figured stuff
out and they they maybe plan the trains
and stuff but you know I think
everything kind of sounded overwhelming
when I like told them I was like okay
I'll just figure it out so like I I
booked them a a taxi from Narita to to
take them to the hotel which is like two
hours right expensive taxes for me yeah
I'm paying it why didn't you just throw
them on the narrator Express oh because
I was like man they're gonna they're
gonna be overwhelmed absolutely first
time in Asia having to figure it out
like also first time in Asia yeah yeah
yeah okay yeah and I think there's still
that like and I realize that everyone
has this where you're like oh no it's
like English will be okay right like and
it's like yeah no it won't be okay maybe
on the Naruto Express yeah okay like
it's like I'm sure like this is not me
being like all right it's not about I do
I think they could figure it out yeah
they could figure it out but yeah it's
like all right do I really want to put
that stress on them right away it's like
okay I could just get them a cab and
I'll front the cost and then all they
have to do is just look for the guy with
the name and then apparently that
somehow that [__] up too because it
was like 4am because we were in Hawaii
yeah and I was like you know I was
making sure that when they landed I was
like hey did you get in the cab okay is
it all good and they're like yeah it's
all good it's all good
and I I want I was going to go to sleep
when I knew they got to the hotel and
they could finally you know rest and
then I I wouldn't have to worry then
about you know because I booked the
hotel I booked everything everything is
all booked by me and I was like I just
didn't want like a [__] up where maybe I
put the name wrong or something you know
what kind of did actually [__] up
because I I remember uh I remember
because uh his parents it's not it's not
just his parents that have come along
but we have a friend from England who's
flowing all the way here that I think
landed on the same day as your parents
two days after two days after all right
but like I remember thinking uh so I
remember Conor was like mentioning oh
yeah I'm gonna come back from Hawaii
then pick my parents up and I was like
wait a minute I was checking the dates
because I was having to make sure the
dates of when our friend lands as well I
was like wait a minute Connor mentioned
his parents come back on this day yeah
but we fly back on from Hawaii the day
after that was the one thing I did time
zones I'm like does Connor realize this
or I did realize that and I told my
parents that but then I didn't tell my
friend that so yeah it's kind of like a
miscomication because there's so many
things
like three people and then myself which
is already I'm not going to keeping
track of yeah yeah so so I you know I
got them a taxi and I'm in the Hawaii
hotel room and then they're like oh we
think the taxi driver is going the wrong
way I'm like I don't think the taxi
driver would go the wrong way I gave
them the address how would your parents
know I don't know because they're just
freaking out right they just haven't
been to it and everything's new and the
tax driver doesn't speak any English
because of course I don't speak English
uh and so they call me up and they're
like I think the taxi director they're
talking to me in Welsh and my mum calls
me while she's like I don't think they
know where to go yeah I replied in
English I was like Mom I don't think
they can speak English I don't think you
need to speak to me in Welsh
um your mom's trying to be like the
screen yeah you don't need to worry
about it
and even if they did speak English they
wouldn't understand like British English
yeah yeah you did yeah um and so they
hand me the phone I'm like okay fine
okay they're like yeah we think the taxi
driver's going the wrong way I'm like I
don't know I think it's fine so they
hand the phone to the taxi driver and
the taxi driver's like it sounds like a
young woman and she just sounded like
terrified that I think my parents just
shoved phone to her and then some weird
guys talking Japanese to her and so I
was like he's a ransom calling I was
like hey uh my parents are just kind of
nervous
um do you have the address and she just
sounded like utterly panicked by that
question and I was like all right then
she's like oh she's like freaking out
you can imagine how it is yeah it
sounded very flushed and very panicked
and I was like all right then and I know
I was like I'll just hand it back she
handed it back and I was like yeah she
knows where she's going I didn't know I
was like I was like
meanwhile everyone in that cab is
sweating yeah I'm like don't worry about
it I'm sure she knows and of course she
knew where she was going yeah yeah um
and I was like this is so stupid but
then you know and then I think it
proceeded to be like all right let's
every little thing well I'm not there
they would like worry about it and then
like double check with me and so the um
the first day we had to do we have to
record trash days no I had to do
something I have to do a live stream
yeah and so I was like hey just just go
here for lunch walk around and so
they're walking around and they're
texting me stuff and they're like oh we
found like a a cafe to drink and they
sent me a picture and my God it looks
like the shittiest Cafe in all of Japan
it's like it's like yeah it's like it
has an outside Terrace and it's it's let
me show you a picture yeah okay it's
like unfair to even call this a Terrace
do they not just think to like walk into
like a Starbucks I think I think they
didn't want to go to Starbucks and also
I think they were also like look at this
[Applause]
and this is something that I've learned
and I know this because I had the same
thing myself like it is super
intimidating in Japan for people who've
never gone to Japan or Asia in general
to to to imagine having to go into a
building without being able to see it
immediately what's inside yes yeah so I
think for them my parents it was like
okay well Terrace equals I can kind of
see what's going on and then there's
also hundreds of miscommunications they
keep telling me about where they're like
my mum is obsessed with cider as a
British woman yeah wants to drink siding
alcohol excited yeah which just doesn't
exist in Japan no no and in America it's
called hard cider but here it's like
what do they call it Cedar it but then
there's also normal cider which is yeah
you can imagine
but even this is just assuming because
she's like oh do you have silent like
yes we have cider and they bring up
gingers
so this has been a constant frustration
right now where I'm always just like
every single place we go to I'm she's
like do they have side I'm like Mom they
don't have cider I'll tell you when they
have cider mum which is never because
they won't ever have it yeah like
ironically enough the only place in
Japan that has cider are British pubs
yeah exactly yeah that you you probably
uh find more chance of getting a slider
at a hub you know
I get it right because I remember when I
first moved to Japan right there's
there's a big barrier you have to get
past in terms of like just going into a
restaurant and committing to opening the
door yeah oh it's so terrifying yeah
yeah because once you commit now like I
still do it but yeah there's a
millisecond I mean I hated it and I
could speak the language yeah because
you're like once you open a door you're
like [__] I've committed to like sitting
down at this yeah I don't want to be the
[__] that immediately turns yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I've had to become because you know I
was and at some point I've been sharing
my friend come with my parents around at
the same time right yeah and it means
that like and they all love drinking so
I've had to become the vibe Checker
which I mean I have to you just have to
walk into a you know a narrow building
on like the fifth floor of some really
sketchy looking thing and I have to pop
my head and be like oh no no sorry yeah
go out and it's pretty awkward but and
like my dad as well he's um he loves
beer and every single time when we get
we get a beer he's like what beer is it
I'm like I've never known it's normal
yeah it's the draft one yeah which one
is it I don't know I haven't I've never
questioned it in three years it just
always comes out tasting good so I just
I've noticed every time he asks me I was
like I just don't know I just drink it
it's me it's fine I'm like I every
single time he likes the beer
it's just like it's just it's very fun
taking them around but after like like
multiple days of this I've been getting
this same question I'm like I'm losing
my mind losing my mind being asked these
questions over and over again but it's
been fun they love the bullet trains
everyone seems to love bullet trains as
well every foreign person I think people
from outside Japan just like find that
concept so insane yeah because it's like
well like I think like China is the only
other country that has trains that go
that fast yeah I think I think no Europe
has has high speed rails does it yeah I
don't think it's as well connected
nearly as well connected yeah run on
time or I think like a million people a
day use the shinkansen which is like
insane amounts of well I think it's all
just also just like I wouldn't say like
the marketing but like the prestige
because it was actually like one of the
first and one of the most famous right
it was the Japanese bullet trade yeah
like this is where and this when like
Japan was in the Heights or when you
think Japan you think the bullet train
yeah this is when Japan was like the
height of the center of Technology sure
you know yeah they loved it yeah and
that that image is just like stayed
because even my parents right I was I
asked my my mom and dad when they come
to Japan what do you want to do my dad's
like take me in the bullet train I was
like that's uh unaware out of everything
that's what you want to do okay Dad okay
he's just like I'm excited for the
bullet train yeah yeah I mean it's fun
it's all about the destination it's
about the journey yeah yeah exactly that
is the destination
the bullet train is great seeing at the
when the train leaves at 9 57 I can tell
them look at the clock when it turns 9
57 the trains oh that's my favorite
thing it is yeah
I'm like that's sick that's awesome
um I mean they love that my dad is
fascinated by it he loved all that uh
they I mean they like it so far like in
uh most of the food they like I've made
them try pretty much everything yeah and
they are they like generally okay with
like food like is the food palette wide
or I thought it was like non-existent
right I thought they weren't going to
eat anything right but then they've
eaten everything like it was good we're
gonna have dinner and uh yeah there's
one place I only serve like raw meat
yeah it was it was basically a a place
that specialized in raw meats and fish
and we realized that after sitting down
and like half the menu was just like raw
horse Meats raw beef oh yeah baby shrimp
and every every kind of raw meat yeah
this is a little baby looking squid
thing that's common in spring in Japan
and uh that was the appetizer that came
out maybe yeah and it just looks like oh
yeah
yeah shrunken down yeah yeah that was
like the first thing my parents had it
was kind of different they were like I
was like try it in like Dark Souls yeah
yeah usually their credit they they ate
one of them they didn't no they they try
at least they tried it I was impressed I
thought no shots yeah eat it and swallow
it they didn't they didn't spit a single
thing out oh that's good yeah I took
them to a sushiro as well because I was
like I was like because I'm gonna take
them to a nice finest job yeah so my
thing was I wanted them to try
dirt cheap sushi and so you know like
this is what it should taste like yeah
like this is like compared to the UK
have you ever had UK Sushi before yeah
they have they have they like it I think
they liked it yeah but I mean again
they'll never eat it again yes yeah and
like it was very westernized but I
couldn't you know I mean I when I go to
sushi or something I don't try anything
[__] crazy stuff I just get the
standard oh no no no no I'll get like
I'm not having the [__] hamburger
Sushi no no no [__] that [__] yeah yeah
and so like you know they were like yeah
it's nice yeah I don't think they like
loved it yeah they pretty much enjoyed
it but they recognized that it's like
even the yeah the minimum here is better
than anything again kept saying uh oh
it's not it doesn't smell fishy I'm like
yeah yeah I think so yeah yeah
um and then uh tempura they liked you
went to a really nice Temple oh hell
yeah yeah foreigners loved him I mean
it's just fried food isn't it like yeah
what's not to like about fried fruit
well I I mean I gave so this is uh
tempura restaurant in uh called
um
oh that's called tempura
and or something uh Chris took me to it
because it was like it's almost crisp
way of telling yeah yeah it's really
famous in Kyoto and Christianity there
Chris the way Chris sold me on it
because it was like it's like 200 of
course damn it's crazy Chris is like no
no it's Steve Jobs's favorite restaurant
I think it's really good to be fair yeah
they give you like 15 pieces of tempura
and stuff and they loved all of it you
know I I because they give you like like
shrimp head as well where all the tail
and stuff yeah and that's like I [__]
love that yeah it's kind of like all
right try it don't judge just eat
everything again they loved it all
except for uni uh seochin which they
none of us like that is a hard bargain
yeah
it is the Marmite of Japan so I'm slowly
starting to find out now uh yeah Eugene
came with us as well and yeah tried uh
our friend of ours uh did he like uni no
yeah
he immediately texted meleen saying hey
I don't like sea urchin and then Malene
responded oh you probably didn't have
Goods here
mainly it's like Michelin yeah yeah
this is my weekly slander yeah
um yeah uh tried um so I also we were in
uh okay so I'll tell you what we did
first of all yeah where did you take
them so uh did like uh I thought let's
because I I haven't got like super long
it's like we're still working yeah I
just got off the bullet train from
bringing them back and I'd come straight
here to record
um so I wanted to make kind of a densely
packed like four or five days of no
ghost ball I hope no girls boss sadly
that's only Sydney thing man yeah yeah
that's a tough sell I also realized that
like maybe because Sydney's family is
probably a lot more outgoing than my
family like they'd probably be able to
interact themselves whereas for me it
was like I had to translate everything
and I don't even understand everything
100 of the time right your family at a
[__] girls bars the funniest thing
ever after some really weird bars that I
was insistent on going to because I
thought it'd be really fun experience I
think they're pretty fun so the first
day we went to a uh it's like an Onsen
Winery thing I think we've talked about
before so I took them to there and they
loved that that was great yeah did they
go in the answer they did yeah
yeah like a lot of convincing no no I
just kind of like I kind of like just
didn't tell them anything about that
anywhere we were going to I was like you
I could tell you but it's not gonna mean
anything yeah I told them I was like hey
go in the spa do it here we go have fun
and they I think they they were
definitely shy about it but I think they
enjoyed it yeah yeah yeah I mean who
doesn't like a hot spring it's nice yeah
yeah exactly and then the food that's
really good and stuff it's lovely if you
get a chance to go just I think after
what's called just Google nigato Winery
on scent it's chill yeah you should
check it out it's awesome